[Music]
all right following up from our last
episode that lives there hours after
hours the deeper cut we were rocking it
with Rick and so now we want to dive
deeper okay you were saying before we
started this that until the age of 30 or
so that we tend to not even really
understand some of the patterns that we
get ourselves into teach us unpack this
more this age of 30 well I mean I I
started studying alchemy but I don't
read anything after the 17 at the 18th
century just it's worthless after that
because the the logical reasoning
mindset has already betrayed the
information that is in there
metaphorically cuz they're like oh I
don't know what that means and they take
stuff out because they don't understand
how it fits and so therefore you can't
really learn it but
ask me that question again I'm sorry
just that that we're healing for example
I'm 26 and I'm approaching 30 a lot of
these are already saying a lot of things
are already changing for me biologically
spiritually emotionally always things
happening fast and you're at that age
right now that is really important
because let's just say I've come to
understand things that other people know
this it's not like it was a big thing
that prepares says but the planets are
really influential on you like I've been
watching the moon now for months
like on daily hourly I don't watch it
hourly but I do look at it when I hat
when I'm started feeling certain things
and I'm like okay where are these coming
from because I know I'm conscious I'm
not doing that so I want to understand
the influences that are going on and
what I've come to understand is Saturn
if you hear people say Oh Saturn return
Saturn return what that really tells you
is you know you've got 365 days you get
one cycle of the earth going around the
Sun right and every planet has a
different number of days that get around
the Sun Saturn takes the longest orbit
so technically all the planets are
influencing you through all these
avenues which let's just say it's your
astrological chart
well Saturn stays in each each thing for
like two and a half years or something
in each house where the moon is going to
and-a-half hours right so you're getting
that repetitive feeling and you can
understand the patterns but Saturn is a
pattern that you didn't even see one
complete revolution until 28 years out
and Saturn is a very influential pattern
so it isn't until you conclude a pattern
that you have an ability to measure
against it so after 28 you will start
realizing there's things that I'm I'm
this is the same thing this is happening
again right and so
but one place that I think we have to
start here is just that there's so many
scientists and philosophers and others
that just are reluctant to be humble to
admit that the planets have some sort of
an impact and influence on on our lives
and they're just so such massive
celestial bodies because you're bringing
in so much great area for them now that
alchemy they didn't even this is what
keep me off and alchemy was recognizing
when I was reading the way that let's
just say if you were in this room if you
were an alchemist and you got sick
whatever you needed to repair that is in
the environment you don't have to go to
India and get tumeric from India to fix
this problem I mean you can do that
today because it's available back in the
day they would heal you with something
of the environment so they didn't like
oh every time this happens you take this
and that's how you get rid of that no
because the planets were altering you
they might tell you you're gonna be sick
for three weeks we can't treat you until
the moon is in this configuration so
you're just gonna have to wait it out
for three weeks and then we'll fix it
so what they would have to know is your
birth chart in order to understand what
are all the influences going on with you
right now that you got sick in the first
place they were looking at functions
they weren't looking at germs and they
were looking at pattern and they knew
how to interrupt pattern they knew how
nature was operating and how to
interrupt nature or advance nature or
diminished nature and that's how they
would heal so alchemy had many amazing
things but because it's not logical
that's why chemistry replaced alchemy
because alchemy is about synthesis
chemistry is about analysis and because
the mind went for logic and reason and
after linear thinking and they elevated
the mind over the emotions at that time
because the the the will was waking up
the Renaissance was a time where the
human will
had come into fruition but what they did
was they elevated it above all else and
really human beings can dominate and
could do whatever you want you can
control anything you want alright so
they got into this structure and they
let go of the enchanted life that the
earth was the son was born every morning
and the moon went to sleep and all that
stuff was no it doesn't go to sleep it's
just going around in a circle and that's
your so you they we lost enchantment we
lost our oneness we lost our connection
with all that was and we needed to in a
development you need to understand that
will is this thing and I need to learn
how to work with will now we're at the
end of what's possible for will without
the emotions so what's happening now is
we're in a society that's left the
emotions behind use taken diminished
imaginations just an imagination and
that doesn't do anything you know what
are you going to do with that degree
great for you when imagination is the
main reality creation tool so chauvinism
has taken hierarchal thinking and made
that the empirical epitome of the way
that you figure something out so now
what's happening is we're diminishing
the planet because we don't understand
how to work with the planet so the
planet is just being used up and so and
there's a belief there that things end
like I've been saying for many years
you're gonna see extinct animals coming
back because it's an energy animals
don't evolve in a linear sense when the
environment is right boom reality
happens so they're gonna keep finding
their you and I just saw a bird this
week they said others Birds been extinct
and they don't know how it came back and
it just and I'm telling you guys I told
you because its energy and if the energy
moves into a different construct there's
gonna be different animals surviving
different animals go away that's alkyl
it's synthesis if you back to plant it
up let's say we are doing things that
making the planet we're having to react
like geoengineering it's you're causing
you're interrupting the natural flow
because you don't understand there is a
natural flow so you're interrupted the
planet's going to try to configure
itself into harmony again so you
you're gonna make the weather make
extreme changes in the weather trying to
balance itself out because you created a
high that wasn't there you know what it
means so alchemy is about synthesis and
so is conscious reality creation it's
like we are synthesizing a relationship
right now between you and I this can't
exist without you and I it's like when
you're talking to Ron for instance and I
could feel that you're trying to word it
in just the right way that he doesn't
get mad because you don't want to
trigger him but you want to say
something and what's happening is
happening it but but what's behind is
your the anger and the frustration that
you want something you want him to grow
or you want him to have a change and I'm
getting frustrated so I'm trying to like
and then he snaps right back you see in
reality creation you're gonna notice oh
that that happened because the anger was
more intense than the good feeling and
so the reality and since he's anger he
gives you back the anger that's more
intense that was me covering up
something that I thought I could hide it
that's what everybody's trying to do
right now they don't realize you've
polluted your unconscious mind with a
bunch of emotions that you don't like
and so those unconscious emotions are
now manifesting in reality and so
they're doing everything backwards right
now they're contributing to more pain
more separation instead of more
enchantment more synthesis like if the
if you can interrupt a pattern that
means you could speed the pattern up
there's two things here that we gotta
unpack obviously one of them we have to
come back just interrupt totally fine
with me
okay we have to come back to the 28th
year Saturn return but yeah it's all
good structure you won't get exactly why
it's critical you noticed and totally
there's so much to unpack with you and
this is what this is a lot of what we do
as well as we focus on all that is and
we love that and laying out the
structure for those at the bell curve
that are there they can pick up like you
were saying earlier all right so let's
let's get to so when you do want to make
a change or when when we do want to how
do how do we say this we want to future
author for ourselves
in an environment that makes it so that
you mentioned earlier you want to be
100% you and love you but and also 100%
love the person exactly where they are
but you want to offer a future where
there's a more even more harmonious
relationship so how do you approach that
with like your partner how would I well
for me because let's just say I have an
enlightened conscious reality creator I
naturally always put the responsibility
on me yes I take the power naturally so
I always take that so in a relationship
with me
you'd always find me taking that whether
it's a friendship or a lover or I'm
always going to take the lead because
I'm just thinking that way and I'm
already seeing the limitations that I'm
I'm addressing them in real time
conscious reality isn't like a
conversation then I go home and beat my
wife this is who I am 24/7 yes in the
grocery store I'm changing people
everywhere all the time because I'm
engaging with my internal construct
about being more powerful so when I love
someone it's because I know that that's
the most powerful thing I can do and
anything else is just a limited
perspective and so if I feel myself not
wanting to do something I have to look
at why do I don't want to do this it may
be a good reason why I don't want and it
may just be a poor reason that I don't
want to but either way I will always
look I want to know why am I feeling
this way right now why am I getting
triggered by this person yes it's not
what they're say but wait if they're
saying it to me we're sharing something
and if I really question the person well
I'm gonna find out what's going on
inside of myself by being loving not
like why do you think like that no go
look you know I again I don't know how
to say cuz it's not a real if it was
really going on behind it I would know
exactly how to articulate the love well
let's say if it's hypothetical I don't
really know how to do it take the actual
issue that we were at and we'll get back
to Saturn so then okay in this example
where you saw me kind of like trying to
navigate
press Express yes so how would one
figure out or me how would I yes stop
with the one how would I myself figure
out how to we were working together I
would have said okay so you're angry
because he got mad I know you're a if
you don't know I'm not angry I'm like I
know you're angry you have to find it
you have to be first step to change his
recognition if I can't recognize that I
can't change but if reality if you say
something and I could see that you were
like upset if and they were trying to
word it and I could see and then his
response was like ah well I don't
remember what he said but he did come
out like that he even kind of did that
like well well you're [ __ ] up right
and like he exemplified what was going
on but that was going on I say okay so
what do you think you're angry about
that's what I would ask you and you'd
have to like now you have to think
because you didn't realize I hear yeah
what what we why were you mice if I
figure out how to say something and then
I trigger someone else to be angry then
it's actually anger and me yeah you're
angry and you created that he got angry
back okay and then so then let's do a
deeper dive then okay
so I'm angry now okay what do you anger
cause probably you're gonna find you
have a negative belief about him so what
are you angry about why did you want to
him to open up maybe the lack of belief
that there are people that are watching
the content the conversations for longer
durations and that are very interested
in hearing what the person were
featuring has to say and what were the
conversations so as he's like like they
have to stay in a certain window of time
yeah right so what's happening is you're
not feeling free
yeah you're not feeling free to create
because the person that you're creating
with is telling you something else yeah
so you're getting mad at the restriction
that you feel yeah but what you have to
find is
my belief is restricting me that I'm the
one that thinks that people aren't gonna
watch this stuff there well alright and
again I might not have the language
right you've got to go for the sentiment
okay let's go for the sentiment thing
okay so right cuz what's bothering you
is the fact that he's not in alignment
with this longer-duration vision what
what are you now now I want you to
articulate that better what are you mad
about now that he's not what that I'm no
just talk about him right now okay what
do you mad at him about we'll get to you
yeah the lack of vision lack of vision
yeah the lack of it and so that vision
is what that vision is building out the
long-form nuance driven content and also
building out the libraries for us to be
able to go and make highlight reels and
shorter clips from in the future and
whatnot and he doesn't want to do that
no no it's something he doesn't want to
do that
sorry it's more that that that the
highlight reels and all the shorter
content and all that other kind of stuff
will come later and that will likely
either be myself working with teammates
or maybe just teammates that are doing
that stuff but Ron right now is slowly
allowing I think himself to increase
from keeping a show within an hour no
matter what to occasionally if we have a
guest that he likes oh he enjoys the
conversation that he'll let it go to an
hour and a half or two hours hmm yeah
and I'm grateful for that I'm grateful
for that I'm extremely grateful for them
extremely grateful that he is even
sitting down to do the production in the
direction of the shows so what if you
first off then you got to recognize you
share belief see since it's your
unconscious and that's the feedback if
you come from I'm the author of what's
going on here now I have to say okay
what am I really wanting I want to go
longer
and I want the support from him yeah
that's it that's so I'm not feeling
supported that's what you're mad about
okay yeah I'm not feeling supported okay
that's a pretty good way to put it yeah
and so yeah I feel like I'm rushed that
we can't sometimes get to some of the
good or the good stuff at that yeah yeah
the conversations got rolling yeah yeah
so but what belief is there now you
might want to even go deeper like okay
because you want to be clear like now I
know I'm not feeling supported that's
that resonates I could feel that so now
we want to know what is it you're not
being supported in because let's just
I'll give you it see it's hard I have to
go longer to try to speak to someone
that doesn't have the language that I
use but let's just say an example as a
kid you came up with an idea that people
don't support me when I'm something is
really important to me
I'm not supported when it's but only
when it's really important because I get
supported in other areas you see now you
want to understand what kind of support
is it because that's gonna lead you to
where you created the belief in the
first interesting so what kind of
support is it it would kind of be like
the loving caring work together through
things in a gentle way how do we figure
out how to exactly do it in the best way
kind of thing yeah yeah so would you say
it's a mothering support or a fathering
support these are hard questions I don't
know how to answer them yeah well but
let's just say a mothering love comes
from unconditional fathering love is
conditional oh I don't know this is hard
stuff yeah well I'm going into because
you're connected to your mother you grow
out of her it's your connection your
soul your feminine right so that is your
connection to unconditional love I grew
out of it it's now whether she gives it
to you is a different story but that is
my representation of unconditional love
now if I have a negative relationship I
came in here to learn about
unconditional love so I created
resistance with the unconditional love
figure it could even be the father but
we're talking archetypal mother
love it's unconditional yeah the father
is conditional that's why you don't
really get around till dad to about
eight to ten years old or like dad can I
go with you to the store I don't want I
wanna be his mom I wanna be with you can
i watch you fix the car can we watch the
car together what you're trying to is
earn love now you're trying to earn from
somebody you're trying yeah I got
unconditional love I got back now I want
to like get somebody to love me for who
I am and so you start learning
self-esteem from the father now whether
you get it or not is so what I'm getting
at is when you realize like I'm not
supported in what ways that our mother
anything all right [ __ ] because now
you're gonna get another piece to wear
this belief was created mmm that's good
stuff yeah interesting so the mom's love
is that unconditional love the father's
love as a conditional love that we earn
or earned
yeah they're there outside of you this
dude's been wandering in the house and
stay won but what the [ __ ] is it cuz I
love my mama it was like that then you
want to do things to like impress them
and because you want to earn that and
you realize there's another way to get
love I because in conscious reality
that's what you're either creating
reality or you're allowing reality most
people are allowing reality and when
you're allowing reality that comes from
my resistances because it takes density
for physical reality to construct itself
and because you don't know you're doing
it the worst densest part of yourselves
are what's manifesting it's all
everybody's shadow aspects right now
Trump is a shadow aspect for so many
people that are really like I like black
people no I don't I'm not gonna say that
but underneath it my beliefs are black
people are less and so that's coming out
now because it needs to be healed in
order to move forward so that projection
it's like you might the president the
icon of this country is saying those
things then you gotta be like man I got
that going on in me there's no way I can
share the experience with that level of
power without that being something I
really need to change inside right now I
have to look deeper because in my own
conscious mind is okay
okay so then so then the maybe one of
the first things to do
is to look at oneself in the mirror
because it's typically a reflection of
our subconscious out in the world around
us so whether it be with someone like
Ron and I or there be you and your wife
or whether it be our relationship with
the president our relationship with
another skin color or religion or
whatever it may be
is that really dig down into your
relationship with your mom your
relationship with your dad those are the
first two important ones right and then
you duplicate those if you don't resolve
those then you find a lover that's like
my mom or like my dad because I haven't
resolved the issue because my father
wasn't really awake to help me resolve
the issue in the first place okay let me
try and take a stab at it
maybe maybe is possible that it's
because it is potentially it's a nod and
maybe not an unconditional maybe it is a
conditional love and maybe it is then
something along the lines of like
wanting to I want respect respect what
I'm trying to do here and do you see
that's why now you're like that's
actually more father thing I got going
on than a mother right because now
you're defining it and you realized what
resonates you just keep taking the
machine apart you follow what resonates
and it'll get you where you need to go
emotionally is how you figure out you
don't think it you don't think it
through because you can't access your
unconscious mind if you think it through
you feel it through yeah you have to
feel the flavors that rears of it yeah
and and and it's gonna it's gonna take
you down some very interesting past
hopefully to be very vulnerable and open
like Rick I can't sit here and open up
while trying to simultaneously stay
closed off I have to be willing to open
up completely and that's a beautiful
process when you work with people that
when even that's why I love my job yes I
mean that's what I love about is like
when people trust me and I'm like okay
dude I'm gonna [ __ ] blow you out I
got you you know and I can't do that
with masses of people there's no
intimacy in it like I tell but if I talk
to a big room like let's say more than
12 people that's a big room like 60
people there's times I've talked and 60
people
and I'm like I'm talking and I'm feeling
the reality while I'm talking and if
there's so many people and they're doing
so many different things in their head
that I'm having difficulty where do i
frame so what I do is I say I have 12
people in the front I only talk to you
12 people the rest of you are witness
and watch but in order for me to do this
well I have to be connected to fewer
people so I can read how reality is
playing out with me as I'm talking to
you yet because you want to be able to
be tapped into that feedback loop that
there has to be an emotional feedback
and it is it too much to have a theater
with a hundred or a thousand or even
10,000 in a stadium people it's too much
even though you can feel like a big
reaction from the audience when you say
some pure resonates but the thing is
it's like the journey is in the intimacy
if I'm talking to like a bunch of
nothing I can't connect I can't get any
feedback of myself I'm just a voice
spitting out a bunch of dialogue you
know yeah maybe everybody will laugh
because that was you know I knew they
were gonna laugh right there but I'm not
really engaging somebody and trying to
heal them trying to go deeper into their
process so it's personal you know like
when people travel about like a like
what if this happened what would you say
I was like I can't tell you because I
don't have the real person in front of
me to go deeper I can only guess and
then when you guess you can only guess a
couple levels and then you can't go any
farther either okay so let's start
breaking it apart in the sense of that
when you have a some something that
you're that you're feeling that you're
reflecting on whether it be your partner
your president all this type of stuff
that you want to start looking at
yourself and your relationship with your
mom your dad unconditional love
conditional love you want to start
breaking things apart by feeling how you
feel with those things and so you don't
get down to the feeling that you put the
program in the first place you won't
unlatch it because let's say this
feeling has ten units of intensity that
put that in and while I'm looking around
I only get to six your subconscious
isn't gonna trade those oh sure sure so
you want to get to the full intention
yes okay so then how would how would you
take someone and we'll get to Saturn
return how would you take - so how would
you take someone to the full intensity
well doing what I'm doing with you now
okay when I get down to the bottom of it
okay when you are gonna be the one that
knows right when you say oh my god I
know exactly when I [ __ ] thought of
this because you will remember your
subconscious is watching you right now
navigate your emotions it'll start
giving you the information when you're
willfully pursuing it interesting so you
think I may have gotten a couple bread
crumbs by digging down to this
conditional love of - yeah and wanting
there to be some sort of a validation
he doesn't validate me it's bothering me
that's that's a good way to put it and
not being validated to do longer form
conversations bothers me yeah there you
go that's a pretty good way to put it
and then you just go I want to ask you
for me I want to feel good about us I
want to feel good about what I'm doing
here because it's a value of mine this
is a value that I'm placed in this
business for instance let's say if you
did it has to be based in a value yeah
otherwise there won't be character
integral you that the content that is
discussed here impacts inspires engages
people around the world so that's the
that's the value so you wanna enlist him
and write you got now you were not sick
what's bothering you about wanting to do
it longer okay because you're gonna have
to resolve that that's gonna be in you -
okay so then the question so it's I want
it so how did you start that phrase I
want to talk about something about nice
and - you want to focus on how it feels
I want to focus on how it feels for me
why does it bother you to go longer in
this well you don't even have to ask him
what you like why what is it in you that
doesn't want to go longer leg what's the
belief because he's probably to say
think like cuz it's a lot more work or
you know he's gonna have an
belief on the backside of that then when
you hear what it is you go could you
change that belief could you change that
way of looking at it oh you asked just
like that yeah it's your reality if he
says no you're like okay then I can't
receive that kind of vulnerability I
can't receive so I'm gonna have to find
another way to do it and more processing
more processing so because everything is
a process yeah yeah if you can't get it
now responsibility is it if yeah it's a
it's a function of women okay so then
the idea is that ask you know what what
does it make you make you feel like yeah
I'm doing cuz I'm feeling bad I with the
validation that want the validation how
does it make you feel I'll tell you one
more piece understand yeah cuz it's
important but he but then the then the
reply would be something like whatever
the belief is about the reply about
going longer and then it's not an if but
it went so then if so then if it's comes
back saying that I don't want to do that
right now it's not one of the things
that came a long time ago is nobody
watches it anyway type thing right so
then it may be that still lives there of
nobody watches anyway and so for me to
not maybe you know flare up but to stage
so that's super important yeah if that's
his response nobody watches anyway then
you got to go inside of me what I'm
doing doesn't have value yeah somewhere
inside let's say if it was from my dad
not acknowledging me and so I don't get
that acknowledgement and so I'm not
feeling the value that I'm putting out
and he's telling me nobody watches it
anyway so you got a look at
metaphorically what is that if somebody
says back to me that's because there's
no value in what I'm doing somewhere I
don't see the value where I don't see
the value yeah because if you see the
value you need him to go longer yeah
yeah yeah and you would have to ask I
would really appreciate sometimes I want
to counter also and just say that
although there is truth to the wanting
to hear feedback from people that gets
you to reflect deeper on your vision
and understand maybe there's a different
way to package some of the content to
make it wah watched more and all that
kind of stuff for sure at the same time
I can also say that a year ago when that
comment came up there was no viewership
subscribership content database that
we've accumulated now so it's taken me
to just be stubborn about the vision in
order for it to get to this point now
where it's easier to do a longer form
conversation because it's grown
significantly and the same thing will
happen in a year where it will I think
this is how I feel about it that in a
year once things are even more uphill
that it'll be even easier now do you see
what you just spray yeah yo you said in
a year it's gonna be more and then okay
see that's not valuing it now now okay
yeah I mean I'm not trying to bust wood
everybody what does the future authoring
go right but you want to have that
future now okay then I will get there
because it doesn't need to take a year
it doesn't even it could happen tomorrow
but see right now it's not gonna happen
tomorrow cuz it's gonna take a year you
just want to be open to you know I have
a belief construction saying that later
with you get more is better that's kind
of the same thing when 8 million people
agree then we're gonna be powerful yeah
yeah kind of the same kind of logical
linear progression of things you know
cuz here it is now and the way I
pictured if we did this much work I
could see it taking another year it's
like that's not interrupting the pattern
that's letting the pattern take you and
then okay letting Oh gotcha okay so this
is kind of like you let the pattern or
program take you to that year or you try
and interrupt the pattern or program
yeah deeper into how you are feeling
that you're gonna have a year from now
cuz that's really what you're going
what's the feeling that you think is
gonna take another year to get and you
can you can you can reprogram that
pattern by dropping into how you feel
with the person that you're talking to
about what is going to happen in a year
from now and trying to talk about it
today right now yeah
in a week this is what I'm into right
now I'm into this longer content thing
and I'm realizing this is where I feel
like there's gold here there's so much
and so what actually with you and your
conversations that you're having with
people as long as they are okay with
having it be filmed I mean this type of
a conversation that's working with
people on long-form video is gold yeah
so beautiful - when everybody trusts and
they know that the space is you know
because when somebody's watching me take
you apart they actually share this - but
they're watching from the other leg of
the triangle yeah you know for a lot of
people that's easier than this oh yeah
and so they still learn it that's why I
love talking in small group little even
at the little bit yeah so even in a
group of 12 let's say you're working
with 12 even if you're working
one-on-one with one of the twelve eleven
are watching how that's going and
they're seeing bits and pieces like okay
you just talked about mom unconditional
love data conditional love where do I
fit in that right and so then people
start really getting deeper themselves
you know that's part of that content too
is that you know they're not the actual
organ 3d printer let's say the person
that's sitting here in the biotech field
or the person that's making the new
technology for protocols for blockchain
technologies but they're there they're
learning about one of the pieces about
the blotching technology or one of the
pieces about the biotechnology with 3d
printing organs all these types of
things so at least getting the tiny
shards that come and then can catalyze
butterfly effects just like when you
break down with someone one of these
patterns and go back and look and go
future as well all this whole process
with someone I think is yeah great to
have okay I think we could probably keep
breaking down that stuff but we're
talking about the SATA return yeah let's
go there yes so so one one thing here
that I mean I mentioned at the very
beginning that I just want to make sure
really resonates that we've heard this
from so many scientists and philosophers
it's just as hard scientific
empiricism where it's like no there is
no proof that Saturn effects or the moon
affect me there's no proof which means
no way you know it leaves out all of the
beautiful gray area of the misery the
magic right and but but here's the other
thing is that I'm also very scientific
and imperious in the sense that I want
to uncover exactly how Saturn in the
moon and the Sun and these large
celestial bodies how they actually do
influence us because a 28 year orbit of
a planet that is as massive as Saturn
has something to do with how we live
here on earth and the moon is such a
massive celestial body as well it's so
close to us a quarter million miles away
it's so close to us so there's no way
that it has no effect so these are the
things and spiritual leaders are now
trying to press more and more into
finding a beautiful ground sorry more
beautiful ground let's say between the
science and the spirituality that cold
well because people have a tendency in
the consensus in the middle of the bell
curve to not listen unless it's backed
by logic and reason for me I don't mind
having some of those conversations but I
have no interest I am NOT gonna talk
logic and reason I don't give a [ __ ]
because it's not I know that that's not
the most powerful thing and I'm not even
gonna bother I that's why I say I'm
gonna talk about magic I'm gonna talk
about intimacy I'm gonna talk about
reality creation and for the people that
like you logs a reason this is not going
to make any sense matter of fact some of
them are gonna get mad oh you think
you're - god oh wow that's that's pretty
egotistical or they say a lot of stuff
like that right good fine I I'm looking
for people that are ready to take
granted responsibly deeper truth that we
all create our own reality 100% I lived
it
I didn't get this idea yes this ideas
out there was out there before I died
but dying and putting myself back into
it with that construct I'm not going
anywhere I'm not going I don't care if
quantum physics ever figures it out
because it's not going to okay okay hold
on weak
our own reality 100% okay got that
locked in hopefully we can all get that
locked and as soon as possible although
I do slightly disagree that that we will
for some reason never get to a point
where science can understand that yeah
you get magnet you ossible that we keep
well it will but it's far behind the
truth okay and now let's venture into
that truth right let's say we're both on
the bell curve in the direction that
you're identifying and that we do
understand that celestial bodies have a
significant influence on our lives what
does it look like a Saturn does when
we're birthed where it the where its
location is when we're birth Saturn is
the disrupter okay teach us right so in
alchemy every planet is like music every
planet is one of the notes in the scale
so as all here's you on the planet and
you're get your going around and these
other planets are going around and
you're getting close and you're getting
far and you're getting in astrology this
is why degrees are important because
there's information in a thirty degree
in a sixty degree in 180 degree there's
information in the numbers so when
there's a triangulation there's a chord
being played now the triangulation could
be between Saturn the moon and you know
what I mean but so those three things
and harmony create an experience so when
you realize that the plant each planet
is a note in the symphony that's being
played at different times in different
moments according to the other that's
why the moon's the number one most
important planet out of all of them
because it affects the rest it affects
us the most it drags the water around
the planet
your water is moving with it so the moon
is the most important aspect more
important than the Sun because it's the
emotion it expressed it's the expression
of the feminine but right now we're in a
very chauvinistic society that's put the
mind over the motions so the Sun is all
important right now it's all about the
Sun when it's really the moon is the
most important influence because the
moon is technically in 28 days it has
its four seasons it has its spring it
has its summer it has its autumn it
it has everything in 27 days each which
is why women also part of them as a
cycle with women exactly because there
that is one whole process and alchemy
when they say it takes a year for this
to happen they really mean a month
they're talking about moon days when
they say it takes a year to do this
process a year to the moon is 28 days a
year to the earth is 365 days a year to
Saturn is 28 years that's why the
patterns all come together and they all
match up with different angles according
to your specific day okay so the
triangulation then of something like a
Saturn plus the moon plus the location I
am on earth that triangulation I have
there's a certain energy yes sir certain
thing it's transmitted immediately
certain thing is transmitted immediately
and that location of Saturn in the
larger cosmos has to do with what is
being brought from that area of the
cosmos where Saturn is - well and it's
instant because we have time the
universe doesn't have time the influence
is instantaneous this is what they've
already in quantum physics they already
know that light is not the fastest thing
in the universe anymore but the entire
physics model is based on light so
technically they might as well throw the
whole thing out but why don't they
because there's justice that is the
fastest it's resonance resonance like if
you take a tuning fork and you put it
here the same one over there and you hit
it this one vibrates with no time in
between it's faster than light that's
how space travel is accomplished if you
have a vibration here and you know how
to duplicate a vibration over there you
can get there now if we have a tuning
fork here and on theoretically yes this
is why for instance a lot of the
cultures like Sirius you know a lot of
the indigenous cultures think Sirius is
this really important star cluster it's
a blue star it resonates with earth
earth is a blue planet that's a blue
star there's a vibration that they share
and there were people on Sirius at one
time that we're coming here these are
the giants that they spoke up
sure so that but there's a resonance
between those two places which enabled
those people to get here easier because
there's a shared resonant vibration
between the two places so there may be a
shared resonant vibration between where
our souls decided to come through the
the bodies on the bond the planet that
may have made well that's why your name
yeah your name identifies the vibration
that Alan is other one you had a
different name you have a different
vibration in the other way so even just
a word Rick and devotion that's with
that is part of your soul names you it
looks like your parents do in reality
but it's your soul that gives you your
name I am the name it's the first thing
that happens when you come into I am the
power that's the second stage of the
soul when you they call it terrible twos
no that's when you have your awakening
psychically you don't even know you're
not your mom until you hit the terrible
twos and you're like no all I have a
preference I want this no no no it's the
first time you realize you are you and
maverick is like almost a year old right
he's almost yeah yeah so you're about to
you're except about to go through the
awakening and I'm so excited cuz like
calling that [ __ ] to terrible twos this
is your awakening and I'm gonna make it
look like oh it's such a pain in the ass
that's right it's a beautiful way yeah
go ahead dude what are your prep what
are your preferences doing haha let me
know let me know if you got a scream
scream you know it's like me that's all
you got you know it's like I learned
this thing that me and him have this
amazing thing we do now it's because I
everybody wants to be self-realized self
determined and they don't have language
and they don't even know how to walk
what I do is I pick him up and I say
okay let's go for a walk and he just
gets quiet because he knows if he looks
at something I walk over to it and I let
him grab it I don't give her a [ __ ]
knife if he's looking at the knife I let
now he doesn't even bother with the
knives in the house because he's I
didn't go oh no no get away from that I
let him look at it when he wanted to
look at it he might do some [ __ ] with
and I'm just watch him close but I don't
get freaked out I let him do now he
doesn't bother with the keys he doesn't
bother with the phone
doesn't bother cuz I just let him have
it I let him have it and let him have
his time with it because everything he
gets involved with he drops in no time
yeah so I let him have it so he doesn't
want my phone anymore he's not bothering
any of our phones he doesn't want any of
the stuff that he shouldn't have already
because he's already looked at it yeah
yeah yeah it's like you see I'm letting
him be self-determined if he looks at
the knife and then he does some stuff
and then I see he looks at the
refrigerator no it's a magnet I let him
III bring him to what he's interested in
sometimes we go down the hallway outside
I take him wherever he wants to go and
he's like I could tell he's learning
like yeah I can have whatever I want
you're letting the the consciousness be
the full full sponge of yeah sponging
let him be what he's interesting that
sovereign tree right off the bat of
being I guarantee you my kid it will be
a very interesting person yeah yeah well
I'm programming him with reality
creation as being his model but liek
when I was a boy my parents were
throwing [ __ ] each other's hitting each
other you know that it was that's the
unconscious stuff was getting put in me
and I got here I don't know what he's
gonna do when he all this stuff is what
he's getting in his unconscious mind we
get along you know if we do get in a
fight our arguments are quick and
intense and over you know mate sometimes
we might get an argument for three
minutes and be like [ __ ] and then we'll
start laughing because she could say
whatever she wants I'm not gonna get
triggered if I'm triggered I'm gonna say
because enlightenment doesn't look like
monotone it's full expression of all of
you because I can get mad and say
something shitty and I could still fix
it I could still be like you know what I
realize just now I was projecting and I
I I'm sorry and she knows how to forgive
me it's like we know how to do it we
know I mean that's why she wanted to
marry me because she realized she'd come
to some of my talks and was like I don't
know what you're saying sometimes it's
but I know you're saying the truth okay
so this point is a you brought it up in
the last conversation I wanted hit it so
it's actually quite good that it came
back up so
notion that we can be fully enlightened
but still express anger yeah and and
that is why the adolescent thinks sadly
no adolescent thinks enlightenment is
peaceful calm and I never get mad and I
yeah well your Johnny one note man who
wants a life where I'm always monotone
walking around I don't get my
preferences met I'm not excited I just
don't want to [ __ ] just for [ __ ] you
know it's like where's your passion
where's your where's your God being it's
like I want slide tennis shoes I want a
good car I want everything that the
illusion has to offer
that's enlightenment it's just that the
adolescent doesn't know that and doesn't
see that because the adolescent thinks
it would just be if I just wasn't mad
all the time and I just was you know
cool
damn okay hold on I want to also see if
we can visit this in a way that isn't it
also simultaneously important to realize
what those things do that the we if we
goods being emotions or let's take both
examples let's take the example of like
an anger where this these teachings are
like thousands of years old where we can
do something like really get to the
deepest roots of ourselves to be able to
cognize more and be patient and rather
than react right away and get pissed so
why don't you want to react right no way
I get pissed because most of the time
and I think most of the people that
watch that also meditate realize this
that that when we get react and get
pissed right away that yeah technically
you're right that we're feeling
something but at the same time we're
also feeling it when we feel it within
ourselves but that we realize that we
can be a quantum as' and that we can
react to the situation in a way that
actually potentially catalyzes a more
positive so that's a great plan right
but it doesn't work because you're not
fulfilled if you're
suppressing your emotions you see don't
know if it drives me out well here's the
thing the child in the adolescent don't
know how to be responsible with their
emotions so when they got mad and threw
a fit I didn't get what I wanted so I
know that I shouldn't throw a fit I
shouldn't get mad so so much cancer the
cancer is a function of rage
suppressed rage and not being able to
change when you take those functions out
of a person they usually can heal their
cancer you see you are supposed to be
self expressed all the time now if I get
mad and I punch you in the face you know
that's way out a lot and getting mad it
shouldn't be a problem for you if I get
mad if I don't like what's going on here
what the [ __ ] is happening [ __ ] you got
what are you doing what's wrong with
that that's honest they need to see the
honest feedback of their impact and if
I'm like well I'm not gonna get mad
because I'm gonna figure out how to talk
to them but I got to communicate honesty
without rage and you know you honestly
get raged you don't punish anyone with
your rage that's what people do with
their rage they don't just express it
they do something with it
they make somebody wrong or they judge
somebody or they hurt somebody or they
hit somebody or they flip them on they
do something instead of realizing I'm
mad that's all I am pissed because I
have a limited perspective you still
have to keep coming back to you it's
like you get fit you know when you were
a little kid having a box of eight
crayons was fine then you get the 56 box
of crayon and then you realize I don't
even use half of them that's how your
emotions are you should be using them
all all the time
interesting because otherwise you're
throwing it into the unconscious and
that angers got a manifest somewhere and
you throw enough of it out and you don't
really deal with it let's say if you
want to do it your way I don't really
want to what do I do with that and by
the way it's not even my way it's just
something that I've been taught and been
pricing 4004 that's been communicated
for thousands because the Allison and
child have been in charge of reality for
thousands of years that's what this
paradigm shift is the finally the chain
has come to be something else and this
is the time to step out of that paradigm
you you think that it's possible that
the the multi thousand-year tradition of
rode away a meditation go two ways throw
away because terrible because then you
can do a fifty six crayon fifty-six
expressions of unique so so then the
idea is that as long as I express that
true anger with honest yeah okay then
the person is also with parity and with
care integrity character that the person
also has a a they have a they also are
100 percent them themselves so they can
do things like forgive me when I say
that okay
I was angry there I recognize I was
angry there but they got so here's the
thing I would they want to punish you
because you got out of a line you see
adolescence so there's so so a I get
angry be the honesty arrives with the
other person in its fullest let's say
the honest feedback that I'm trying to
deliver see they get it and I realized
that I was angry and I asked for
forgiveness and deed the person's
forgives me yeah it's okay this now you
generated intimacy okay with getting mad
I got to be honest I got feedback I took
responsibility
they went that direct now where do you
think the conversation is going to be in
30 seconds from where it was before
trying to angle and trying to figure out
a way to to aggress myself that they
don't like you know that's the
adolescent trying to control reality
also though it's it and I and it'll be
interesting to hear what you think about
this but it also goes into in many ways
this emotionally one-upping aggravation
that's the adolescent if you're one up
okay so so the ideas that if if I give
an angry
honest piece of feedback and then the
person says that okay I I get why that
happened or if they freaked out in
return and also give a freak out it just
seems like sometimes that freak out
freak out freak out freak out just goes
up and up and that's because it's to
adolescents neither one of those people
are in okay so then if both are adult
there will be a free because one adult
yeah you won't let it go there okay got
it got it okay so that's why it's a
hundred percent a hundred percent okay
so if there's even one adult it won't
let it go to escalate let's say I get
mad wha and you're like what [ __ ] dude
and I'm like oh I'm sorry dude I could
tell I triggered you but I'm [ __ ]
pissed this is [ __ ] what's going on
here now you're pissed too right so
let's talk about that a little bit you
see you stay in integrity it's hard to
intellectualize this versus like you
said the feeling of it when you're
actually in those moments you will feel
so much fulfilled it's so much closer
and so much honest and so much more free
because you don't have to beat them you
can get mad and handle it the
responsibility isn't if it's wet even if
I don't do it right now I could do it in
the next minute I could do it in the
next minute even if I lose my [ __ ] damn
it it's so interesting because it just
seems as though on the thousands of
years of wisdom that's been brought to
luckily I've been introduced to the
different teachings that have taught me
these things is that that is not
something that is I told everybody's
doing it exactly backwards I'm very
open-minded so the you have you have me
interested okay what is the relationship
of their people some of a lot of the
people that watch actually are right in
the age range of like 18 to 34 so
they're really somewhere around this
Saturn Return I'm in age so what so what
so what's happening when Saturn finally
hits the same place in the orbit around
the star that it was when I was born
well it's so it's a disrupter it's so
powerful Saturn that what happens is you
immediately
see because when you're born you're not
really aware of the choices you made
you're not aware of the positive or
negative relationship I have my mother
to positive or negative really you're
not aware of all that but you're in
pattern when Saturn comes back around
and hits you twenty-eight years later it
starts triggering very deep patterns in
you that you're not even sure what's
going on but I know that this is not
good it's like because you were pre
verbal when those first patterns hit
right you you didn't even know how to
articulate what you were going through
damn but you're in pattern so when
Saturn's a disrupter and it coming when
it finally makes one full circle and
hits again you're dealing with did the
new disruption of twenty eight years ago
was the begin the last time I felt
Saturn in Aries or whatever the hell you
are right so that's when all of a sudden
you start every couple years you go
through the same you're like wow it's
like yeah it starts getting intense
because Saturn is now catching up like
when Saturn when you're like 33 you know
for instance - I'm just using 33 it's
not really special number it's just
special to me but that's like five years
out so you got to figure I'm that is 14
years old now you see all of a sudden
now you're starting to hit patterns that
you can recognize when Saturn first hits
it's just not feeling good about so much
this doesn't feel right with you almost
can't but you know like when you were
seven years old say Saturn was in three
houses over now but you're also more
intellectual you understand better you
have language now so now the patterns
that you're actually hitting a few
meters into the Saturn turn start making
more sense to me when you do a for a
complete second row of Saturn when
you're like 55 is 56 now you've got one
infinity you've got one pattern mimicked
by another experience to look at now who
do I see I've been all this time
it's another big hit when you're about
55 this is where people usually get
older they get wise they get old and die
around that age
they get to be start being a wise more
so because that's when you're really
confronted like wow this has been a
theme my whole life and whatever now
that I see what I was like when I was
raised and then I see what I was like
how I adopted these patterns and I lived
with them for so long you see now you
have a triangulation when you hit 56 I
have this new person that has two
experiences to look at well okay so then
you get the experience of zero and 28 to
triangulate with 56 yes and then that 56
either you get old and die or you yet
you either succumb to your patterns you
go hey I did what I could I only made
this much this was what I did for a
living
I just want my kids to move out I just
want to be by myself now yeah they do
that because they're getting older now
and now they've got to complete patterns
for people that aren't wise it's like
that's the way it is and then they put
the believe that's the way it is you
can't get out of that that's a big
limiting belief oh that's why they start
dying Wow versus the I'm still hella
open I'm gonna build my own reality I'm
still gonna be but you gotta realize for
28 days
for 56 years they've been banging their
head on some patterns so to them it's
daunting that I could change and I can't
I haven't been able to change it in
[ __ ] 55 years that's the way I see it
I mean they take that that's the way it
is and they make it deeper instead of
like wow I've been 56 years of doing it
I got to forgive myself and now I have a
chance to understand two different
perspectives Who I am on a deeper level
like what resonates between those two
examples that I have to understand the
function behind those forms form follows
function I need to know the function now
in order to you can catapult yourself at
fifty six into a new experience or lay
down and follow the patterns for the
rest of you okay years and now let's
let's revisit this 28 quick as well just
that when at the around 28 that we start
feeling some of the initial zero to one
year old programming okay and then so
when we're feeling the 0 to 1 year old
programming when we're 28 then we're
what are we what yes
you don't have words for it because you
didn't have words for it before you were
pre verbal everything was just you were
receiving 100% at that time you came in
people change your diaper people give
you food people tell you weren't doing
it I couldn't walk I was 100 percent
receiving everything I needed I didn't
have to think my way I didn't need a job
yeah that gets taken away from you over
time by the other paradigm now getting
older paradigm control controller
domination versus the Dominion versus
everybody's controlling everybody's
going for control they're not really
creating from the inside and letting
reality tell me how I'm doing cuz that's
what it's for in the first place
reality is a reflection of how I'm doing
on the inside yeah that's a very
profound statement yeah yeah and I need
to learn how to read that and make the
adjustment because when I make a real
adjustment inside and I watch that fall
apart it's one of the most empowering
most fun things you could ever do when
you're like oh my god that was I didn't
have to struggle I don't have to do
anything I could receive that because I
set an environment up to receive
something you're not just like wondering
what's coming next and I'm just waiting
for the universe I don't know what to do
I'm just waiting for the universally
gonna do anything until it hits another
pattern it's just gonna give you another
pattern that's why so many times you can
feel like I'm on the end of success of
all the ages something new and it just
doesn't quite pan out just doesn't
because you don't have the self image to
contain that success you have to move
that consciously that's why I like you
might get a bunch of money and all of a
sudden the car breaks down you're like
[ __ ] man I thought I was gonna be 3,500
ahead and the transmission goes out in
the car because you can't create outside
of the box here in and the subconscious
will just find a way to make it go back
into the box get back into the box get
back into the box because that's the
subconsciousness job to keep integrity
for you so you know when you change
something you recognize when it's
different and what did I do now the
subconscious goes yeah totally that's
the new thing now
and you just live it and sometimes
you'll make a healing and I won't
realize till I see a recording a lot for
God I used to do that because now I'm in
harmony you see you're in a dissonant
when that removes itself honestly
there's no reason for it to exist
there's no reason for that pattern to
exist when I unplug it because it only
exists for me to recognize something
when I recognize the right thing when I
understand the right thing when I can
forgive myself for what I need to
forgive myself then it changes
forgiveness is where the magic happens
and if you don't know that forgiveness
is a process like a grief process and
similar you're not going to get to
forgiveness either it's like how do you
do that oh you just forgive people I
mean you just let it go you just forgive
them if you don't know the process and
it's important thing like little things
is easy to frame what about a big thing
that I don't know if I don't know what
there's a process to forgiveness I'm not
going to get myself through the machine
to get on the other side to forgive and
if I can't forgive I'm not going to
change what is your process for
forgiveness that's a whole thing yeah
but yeah it's a process it's it's a
process it's it's a some journaling and
then it's a meditative process and then
it's a releasing and it's a speaking to
the subconscious to make sure you have
to define it so well that the
subconscious goes I know what you're
talking about
wow this is who I used to be this is who
I am now writing or like yep I
understand it and no more of this and
this is what we want you have to you
have to be able to talk to the
subconscious in a way that it knows what
you mean damn once it knows what you
mean you're you have free will the
conscious mind has the will to shift the
subconscious but you have to understand
how it operates so you can get in there
and make it work for you if you don't
know how to do that
you won't it'll be here to miss Wow yeah
that process so journaling and
meditation and then as part of what I
teach people and because the other thing
is I could explain these things in a way
but if I explain it and you don't get it
and then you think you know it and it
didn't work
that's why I don't not give my stuff
away in public I do it in the right
context because if I give it away in a
less than good way and you think of it
and you're trying it doesn't work here
well I tried that [ __ ] repair said it
didn't really work yeah because you need
somebody to walk on through so you can
they can this is what you missed
Oh your ride didn't feel that enough I
know what you mean now it's like it's
got it that's why alchemy you will not
learn alchemy in a book because alchemy
you needed to take somebody that's why
if you read a book and like oh my master
never taught me how to make the lead
into gold that's because you didn't
understand alchemy if you were to
understood what they're teaching you
would have came to your own
understanding of how to convert that
metal if you're waiting for somebody to
do it you're not self authored and
alchemy is all about being self authored
that's why all the people in the
Declaration of Independence were
alchemists because it's a spiritual
pursuit alchemy it's not a religion it's
a spiritual pursuit and it's like the
alchemy tazewell of our own future
authoring as well this is a major yes a
new the more my resonance was up the
more impact I would have on the
environment so they wanted to be a good
person whatever that means but they
wanted to be a right person a person
with character a person that's why they
did what they said back then and they
didn't waver off of what they said see
the baby boomers did that too but they
didn't like an adolescent and they just
controlled and dominated everything and
undermined everything they didn't alike
like teenagers do you know capitalism is
an amazing idea in the hands of an adult
in the hands of an adolescent it's
terrible it's about dominating and
undermining and not paying attention to
anything right there's no there's no
value-based underneath it it's just
going for money and success but it's not
really understanding it needs to be a
more sophisticated system like what's
the impact on the environment what's the
impact on these people it needs to be
like interdependent capitalism which I
love so much just shout out to June you
and Conrad you and Jeremy you are
getting closer to this loop here yeah
you are you're getting very much closer
to this loop actually this book is like
how to kind of do the
the adult capitalism and not the
adolescent capitalism and and so yeah
you are very close to the loop it's so
funny Rick Rick I yeah I initially met
June and then that I initially met David
Ewing Duncan even before that is crazy
and then I met Andrew through June and
then I met you through Andrew so you are
funnily and Andrews been working with
June's family office for a long time so
here you're like oh yeah it's so buddy
so um
okay really want you to hit on this too
all right
forgiveness is critical for a myriad of
reasons but it also is in some ways can
it be viewed as something that can take
people Oh like for example I'll just
give you an example quicker it's just
that like sometimes it's like someone
gets SuperDuper pissed and then they're
like they don't even say I'm sorry and
then you're the one that's kind of like
always forgiving that and then it
happened - see that's the adolescent
mindset like I are the only one doing it
all the time so then they feel sorry for
themselves they go in to martyr then
they punish the person because I've
already done this three times and you're
doing it again
you see the adolescent can't say I still
haven't let enough of this go or we
wouldn't be in this pattern again and if
you have had if you've had enough of
that pattern it's probably best to just
move on to a different well no you don't
want to move on if you don't plug it now
this is the perfect person to move on
with correctly you think so oh I know so
no wait who are you talking about
whoever yeah I'm doesn't okay let's say
yeah they keep I was just giving
anything yeah I'm like a relationship
between two people right yeah yeah yeah
something like that but if somebody
keeps getting mad and you keep forgiving
them it is your it to be a loving if
you're in an intimate relationship if
the loving thing to do is forgive them
and if I negative judge them I separated
from them so I'm not loving them anymore
yeah but at some point also at the same
time that we have to realize that it may
be that no though you're already going
you know usually
you don't waiter you don't wanna yeah
okay but at the thing doesn't it doesn't
it also at the same time isn't it's also
really important just that they may not
just be the person for you no no it's
your reality every person you're the one
creating them they're the perfect person
for you right now they're the perfect
person for you in either you can learn
how to forgive for your time so it might
be just a day it might be three months
it might be three years or 30 years
right so it might be any of these but
they're the perfect one for that time
period well no for that moment for that
moment for that more for that moment you
have a chance to get rid of a pattern
that I've seen 50 times but if you want
to argue about the pattern say it's
because you just keep getting mad and I
keep forgiving in your not no no you are
mad and you haven't figured it out how
to unplug it so it keeps showing up in
that person that's what I'm saying if
that person is the one that your boss
keeps [ __ ] with you every day that's
the perfect person to figure you don't
want to quit your job and get another
job because you'll find another [ __ ]
that does the same thing what do you do
in this case then the bosses yeah is
it's [ __ ] with you or whatever is
happening and then now you go well again
it's very complex because now I got to
know okay do you got a father issue is
this about earning is this what is it
about this guy that's bugging you
because you got to unplug it if you're
not going to be successful you can't
create another reality by leaving if my
pattern is playing out and this person
just happens to be the best place that's
really reacting to I want to be in the
place where it's really easy to see the
problem okay and then to be able to up
level up by tackling this created issue
like I have to go another round there's
something I'm not getting here okay
thank you for throwing getting I mean
like you don't do it that way but let's
see theoretically thank you for getting
mad again because I need to go deeper
interesting thank you for getting mad
again because I need to go I say you
might not say that in real life but
essentially I've actually said those
exact words
well I I've said that to myself oh yeah
yeah yeah and it's like you you you you
have to understand that's your reality
it's not them doing it to you it's you
doing it and if you get involved with
the negative ego the negative ego
is only supposed to tell you somebody's
mad not like that guy thinks you're an
[ __ ] it thinks you're [ __ ] stupid
right now and you go I'm not [ __ ]
stupid you don't need to yell at me it's
like no you just lost the whole war
right there because the negative ego got
you to go down one of your limitations
because it's real that limitation so
your negative ego uses it against you
and because you know it's true you
believe it and you get involved in an
argument that has nothing to do with the
fact that they just got mad you see it's
like it's not brain surgery but there's
a complexity to it and so if somebody
like my wife it's like there's thirst
sometimes they don't go very long but
there's been things that come up more
than once and it's like okay there's
times I think okay this is the third
time we've talked about this let's get
it out now
what am i doing that you don't like if
it's the 80th time that you've talked to
someone about something I'll never go
that long we see that's the thing that's
what I was just wondering about it
because if you don't know how to unplug
it you're gonna argue about it 80 times
okay okay
right you have to you if you can't
ownership breaking that no I wouldn't
you would never you would find the trash
I want to create from the inside where
it's really going I want to find the the
key own it and then watch the person
stop doing it without me saying you're a
[ __ ] idiot and you need some help
because you need to go to anger classes
you know what I mean it's like that's
all the wrong approach you are sharing
an experience with them and you are both
sharing it for a very good reason you
are both sharing it for very good reason
and then let's say at some point it does
feel as though that you both want to and
that then you can wind it then you can
end it okay but I wouldn't you still
want no but I never do you would start
like it wouldn't I mean because I won't
let it go fifty times when the third
time hits I'm not stopping until we're
done here let's talk about this because
our relationship is gonna move on if we
just keep doing this [ __ ] and if you
know how to in that conversation if you
know how well I do the deepest mom and
dad and the thing is most people in my
life that are it would get into that
situation know me well enough and trust
me like if Rick says this is time to get
into it
it's time to get into it I will create
the reality that they do because I
already am creating much of my RIA most
of my reality I'm creating consciously
and so I don't drop the ball in any
situation that's why I like when people
see me out somewhere and [ __ ] goes down
and they are they watch me do it they're
like this is real deals I'm not just
acting a certain way on camera in front
of people this is how I do it so and
when you see a real moment happen and
you see it happen you're like wow that
was awesome because I don't lose my [ __ ]
and if I did lose my [ __ ] I would lose
my [ __ ] so completely that you'd be like
wow I [ __ ] you're crazy and then
I would [ __ ] fix it do you know what
I mean like for instance I until I was
about I don't know let me think probably
till 10 years ago I gotten probably one
bar fight a week even while I was a
shaman even while I was trying to be a
lion I get in [ __ ] fights cuz I I
couldn't unplug the reason why doesn't
the big guy in the bar that's super
[ __ ] macho think he's [ __ ] more
than me and he always wants to come up
to me and [ __ ] with me and I always got
to kick his ass in front of everybody so
I look good and he it was this pattern
that I was like I would literally tell
someone as I'm about to get in a fight
and they're like what I'm like this guy
right now right watch watch and they
would we just start fighting in the bar
baby like how the [ __ ] did you do that
is it because I could feel I could feel
it when reality is coming and I don't
know what else to do so I just go after
the pattern like I tell the people just
drink the alcohol do it you'll learn you
need to do it and you'll figure it out
just try not to hurt anybody
whoa okay so then you can look at
patterns that are you could that you
would consider potentially harmful to
yourself and others
you have to those are the intense ones
you want to change the most but see this
thing about the harmful patterns that
you want to change it just doesn't seem
like explosive anger is not it that's
you you ever seen somebody in traffic
you're in the car and somebody doesn't
use their blinker and they're like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're
like where's that coming from because
that's how mad they are and that was the
one incident that they would like
release something in a safe way I'm in
my car and this is where I'm gonna do it
it's just the adolescent doesn't have
anywhere else to express themselves so
they create a reality that somebody
doesn't use their blinker so they could
blow up and get the pressure cooker down
hmm hmm I don't know necessarily about
this whole valve
well bi well you're afraid of anger I
could see it I don't know if I would use
the word afraid well why aren't you
embracing it I just I don't know if I'm
using if I'd use the word and frayed or
embrace it's just more that it's more
that um I think there's something about
the multi-thousand your wisdom yeah well
then you're gonna get stuck there let me
just put this out why do you think the
calendars ended because everything
changes in a paradigm and there's no
possible way okay here's the thing I'm
not I'm not saying that that it had that
I'm very open-minded I'm not knows mind
it's a thousand years of tradition I'm
just saying that there is likely
something there know there's nothing
political to in a paradigm shift no
rules apply to the new system none the
more this is why our money system is
breaking our political system is break
everything is breaking already is it not
mm-hmm
because we have to let it go the way
we've been doing it the way we've been
doing it is not getting a result so
since we're not conscious of that what
we're doing unconsciously is just
throwing everything on the ground and
getting rid of it because I just don't
want that in my life anymore
that's the adolescent trying to do what
they always do when they get to a point
where they don't know how to discuss it
anymore there's no complexity well we've
argued for times let's just agree that
we disagree and not talk anymore
how's that great solution so you go off
and find another person to get mad at
and so today you didn't do it why you
had the chance and no big deal
responsibilities when not if so you will
and that's what I mean when you get
older you start recognizing wow man I'm
a
my mom twice I didn't even realize it
till now or I you know you need space
and time to recognize the pattern but if
you right the truth is if you do
something more than once handle it then
if you see something have twice just
handle it then because it's gonna go
three and it's going to go four it's
gonna go five it's gonna go until you do
it but the problem is it's like a funnel
when you're at the top of the spiral you
got lots of time you could blow it off
you could reframe it you could do what
you want and then eventually the thing
always goes down now I have to I got
cancer I'm losing my job I'm losing my
apartment I'm losing everything it's
because I didn't react when I had space
and time to do it now I have to and
there's no power in the choice because I
have to make this choice now and it's
not an empowered choice anymore when you
have to make it and that's what most
people are doing instead of changing the
government like nicely not change the
government the government it's like
capitalism we have the best system on
the planet it's just utilize it by an
adult quit having the adolescent put
more and more laws more and more we
don't have any freedom now we have very
little freedom now and we're wanting
more more laws more laws make them do
that make them they can't do that they
can't do this they need to take those
chemicals out you know the thing is like
house painting I love painting took all
the lead out of the paint because it was
dangerous for the environment yeah but
now you're dumping five times more paint
in the environment now because the paint
doesn't last half as long as it used to
so now you've got to get rid of more
paint waste because it doesn't last as
long with that out there because all you
had to do is get rid of it right in the
first place and use lead in the paint it
last makes paint last for like 15 years
now paint doesn't last five years you
got to strip your house sand it down
start over with an inferior product
that's going to come off again in five
years you know it's like so let's just
not paint houses anymore let's put
siding so you see the creativity is
dropping the options the the freedom is
dropping and this country is based in
freedom yeah it's in the but that system
is crumbling that's why the system of
America was off it was they just said
have check and balances but then they
didn't put it in the party they gave a
two-party system they did that so we
would have to grow again all we have to
do is have a three-party system and the
whole problems fixed just like that you
think it's that easy that easy if you're
having a problem with someone what do
you do you get a counselor you get a
third perspective to watch what you're
doing and talk about it and figure it
out that's what will happen that's what
our government is based in three in the
first place the Senate and House of
Representative a lead to parties now if
you had a third party it would do the
same thing for politics because if you
guys were trying to make an illicit deal
and I was well I mean oh no I know why
you want that to go through and I know
why you're agreeing you see what I mean
it would be checks and balances across
the board and everybody would have to do
the right thing again but they're like
well you got to have 5% before you get
any funding and we never get 5% for a
third party so we guess we don't need
one
no that's the only that's the one easy
move that'll change everything because
triangles are the first geometric shape
after possibility you need your phone
won't even work without a triangle
there's you can't find and you can't
change without it that's why the
government was set up like that but not
finished that way so we had room to grow
and realize we need to implement the
system deeper we need to take it to
another level deeper and demand a third
party be present just to make sure you
guys are all checking in yourself
because then it'll do it on its own
interesting so then the executive
legislative and judicial branches were
made for the checks and balances but
then the by party yeah yeah system that
we have two parties is no checks and
balance you see you learned the game of
tuning the government but they didn't
give you there just so you would hatch
it out and realize the adolescent has to
evolve right now the adolescent is just
freaking out because nothing's working
like my education I'm in debt nothing's
working the way it was supposed to the
American Dream is gone
nobody's dreaming nobody's imagining
when I was a kid every car thing the
future of the car the future of space
look at the new rocket it was like
the 60s the 70s were just all about the
future and dreaming and now I don't you
don't hear anything about the future
much people are just too freaked out
they don't even want to think about it
anymore
it's like they're they're making a lot
of fatal errors in a very unconscious
way the idea is that we can author our
future by doing things like authoring a
third party into the world and then
authoring that state of checks and
balances and then authoring a bridge
between China in the US and authoring a
bridge between Africa as a development
yeah how do we both grow together not
like we're a big country we need to help
you we can help you this much both grow
to you know how do we grow together how
do we do something together if you're
interested you know you know not
everybody has to work together you know
what I mean but you can find a place
that's like in life I can create what
reality should I try to fix the the
career weapon thing or the the nuclear
disaster and you watch it you got to
pick something that matters and then
have a shift don't worry about
everything else going on somebody else
will take care of that not like somebody
but just work on what you want to work
on get the changes in the Araya at that
excite you right but the thing is the
adolescent can't do that because it
doesn't it's not based in a value system
it's based in other people's value
systems you can never be fulfilled
that's why throw all those old I'd you'd
be better off throwing it away and
starting from scratch there's good stuff
in that old technology I just make an
argument for the adolescent cannot
discern what's good and what's bad about
it and adult can't an adult can discern
what part of that religion is actually
doing something beautiful and what parts
should you just throw that [ __ ] away
right now
yeah right that's why the Bible is
filled with half-truths there's so much
Hatcher's you can't discern what's good
information and what's [ __ ] in there and
most of its [ __ ] every religion out
there is shame based everyone if you're
in a religion get out of it drop it and
that's all I tell anyone yeah because
they're in the front of the bell curve
they're still afraid to say [ __ ] you god
you're a piece of [ __ ]
I hate your [ __ ] guts you know if
you're that mad most people are that mad
at God but they're too afraid to get
real God's not going to be mad if you
tell him to [ __ ] off [ __ ] you
the first time I did that I had about a
shop with a lot of Spanish people and I
just snapped one day and I went out and
I Drive what I said and I was still at
this place you know and I was like [ __ ]
you God you [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is that [ __ ] I've been doing it my boys
you start Ronny they were like running
it or or the case is gonna [ __ ] and I
remember thinking wow that's crazy as if
you guys really think that gods like I
like I'm an adult with my baby I
wouldn't get mad at anything he does and
I'm just a human being looking at
another here gods definitely not gonna
react to me telling him to [ __ ] off
you know what I mean like what be angry
adolescent God would like oh yeah but if
I give you this it's because they're all
coming even the god itself as an
adolescent vengeful angry all by himself
that's the Madol essence perspective of
the divine and that idea has just ruined
so much yeah I'm sure at one time was
beautiful it's not beautiful anymore
there's certain things that you just
have to drop and just let it go but of
course you got a lot of beliefs in there
so it's hard like God punishes people
that aren't afraid of them or if you
don't accept him as your Savior
all these beliefs will just undermine
you and the thing is you're afraid in
your subconscious if you do it if you
have a belief that God would punish me
if I said something like that and you
say something like you get punished you
think God did it but no it's your
subconscious just going well that's what
you said you said if I do the wrong
thing you can you they don't know that
it's them and and so I'm just saying
everybody's doing it all backwards and
the thing is if I knew that before but
when I died and put myself back here I
know that I know what I know and I'm not
varying on my position because if I were
to say well yeah sometimes you just got
to let it go and walk away sometimes you
gotta let it go and walk away but me not
me I'm I'm here I'm in it let's do this
right now well we both have a chance and
so that's what I live you know and it
works beautifully people are like God
Rick you're so honest you're so like I'm
like that's just coming out of I have a
set of values that I live by
and I don't very often I had more value
sometimes like the other day I had a
realization wow I really value
efficiency I never really understood it
I like things efficient and so I was
telling that to Andrew and Elizabeth
like I want us to be efficient you know
efficient I love being efficient I'm
doing I literally so efficient sometimes
that I know that in an hour and a half
from now I have to go pick that fire
extinguisher up for there so if the
garbage is next to there I'll throw
something from here and if I miss I'll
leave it there because I know I got to
bend over in an hour and a half and then
I'll pick the piece of paper up I mean
I'm like like doing things in so many
crazy weight because I just like being
efficient but it's like it's a value and
so it makes me feel good when I'm
efficient and it makes me feel good with
things so I get a good feeling out of
this efficiency yeah naturally yeah so
if I incorporate efficiency in every
choice I make is that efficient or not
efficient if it's efficient I'll feel
good about my choice therefore the
choice is going to play out in a
positive way in reality versus I did
that out of duty and obligation I really
didn't want to do it I and then there's
no juice and I don't feel anything I
feel that way too yeah that's Yetta less
at the adolescent does everything out of
duty and obligation because somebody was
telling me what I had to go to school
when I had to wake up when I had it when
I had and I made all my programs based
on some Authority out there that had to
give me what I wanted that's why I have
a job that's why I went to college
that's why I have a boss because I'm
programmed to think I need those things
versus being able to take a self
authoring style we see learn how I was
when I was one I mean I love this point
this point is huge I actually am like
really really a big proponent of this
point about efficiency myself I actually
have people frequently tell me how to
live my life in a more inefficient way
that's and it's like something that I
have to frequently push back on and I'm
just like I I get my authentic self like
I get where I'm at I know why I care
about efficiency across all these
domains it makes you happy being
efficient like not happy actually really
that's another conversation but
happiness is an addiction you don't want
happiness you want joy because joy is an
expression of pref
happiness is my needs are felt if I fill
all my needs and I'm happy now I'm an
addictive cycle because I eat my ice
cream at nine o'clock I get up at eight
and this all makes me happy I'm happy
but what happens is you're in addiction
now wait if you go for preference you're
different every day every moment and
your preferences change and if I go for
what I prefer I'll be enjoying my
process and I have to be in the moment
and be real emotionally in order to
enjoy everything yeah that was probably
one of the most interesting points of
this conversation was trying to figure
out that expressing the 60-plus cran
options of emotion um and also the like
you said there's so much that's
happening with the change in our money
system our political system and all this
type of stuff and so maybe one of the
systems that are getting disrupted is
this lineage of meditative practices
versus this is the adolescent trying to
control having Dominion the only reason
you want to go no meditation is to go to
the more real create something that I
want and see if I can pull it in here
because if I create it in here that's
the first place it has to happen and if
I'm really into the meditation and I
engage my senses and I smell what that
success is like and what is the
furniture feel like in my house and what
are the colors on the wall it creates a
symphony of emotion and XM ffunny of
desire and then I can start expecting
that to happen and what do I got to do
right now to move myself in that
direction you see now you're on a
different armature you're functioning in
a different way and then when that's
backed undervalues and I only go after
my value like for instance efficiency is
my value now I'm gonna do something and
I'm like that's not very efficient but I
can make a lot of money if I do it you
know what I mean it's like for me I'm
gonna say no it's not efficient I'm not
doing it and it's not aligned with your
values yeah exactly from a very first
principles value sort of way Rick this
has been a really strong second
conversation and I just feel like we
need integrate Sabbath also to come on
for I can see your whole you're full to
you fool I'm very full right
but like this would be a great
roundtable with Andrew and Elizabeth as
well and it would yeah it would let me
just look real quick yeah yeah well
let's wrap the show and then and then
we'll we'll do that all right thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
follow-up this deeper cut episode of
with Rick Parris we'd love to hear your
thoughts also check out the links below
to Rick's work again that's conscious
reality creator com the Paris principle
common is LinkedIn profile and also I
would love for all of those that are
tuning in to share more of these
conversations with your friends your
family your co-workers online on social
media get sharing more about how we can
self author our future and also
collectively author a really powerful
future together and that's it everyone
go and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world huge thank you for
coming on yeah yeah and we'll see you
everyone soon peace and I'm excited to
do it with Andrew and Elizabeth again
soon looking forward to that yeah well
this is what I was telling you before
you know it's difficult because I'm
coming from such a different place and
such as everyone much love oh it's still
going sorry I thought we were done